BRADY FORREST: All right!
Welcome to Ignite!
[CHEERING]
That's right.
We've got some amazing
speakers here today.
And just as with every
Ignite, each speaker
is going to get five
minutes on stage,
20 slides, 15 seconds a slide.
These speakers have come
from all over the world
to speak to you today.
And it's going to
be a great show.
Please welcome up our
very next speaker.
And actually, though,
you're in for a treat here.
I've been bugging this woman
to translate this amazing story
into an Ignite talk
for three years.
And this last spring
she owed me a favor.
And thus you get this talk.
Please welcome up
Tindie's Julia Grace.
[APPLAUSE]
JULIA GRACE: Hello.
So this is a story about how
the entire computer science
community changed during
one week in August 2010.
So let's go back in time.
At that period I
was a researcher
at the IBM Almaden Research
Center in a place far,
far away, San Jose, California.
Now, at IBM I wrote
a lot of papers.
And in those papers were
a lot of very complex
mathematical proofs.
Because I like to
subject myself to pain.
Now, luckily I had the office
down the hall from Ron Fagin.
Now, Ron is one of the
most famous computer
theorists in the world.
I'd often go to his office.
And we'd talk about
a lot of my proofs.
Now, in Ron's office
there was a chalkboard.
And next to the chalkboard
with a lot of the proofs
were bills and checks.
And on every single one of those
bills and checks was written,
"If it is proved P is
equal to NP by a date,"
then Ron would cash the check.
So why are people betting
Ron all of this money
that P is equal to NP?
So this is one of the
most fundamental problems
in computer science.
And it's more than just
an abstract math problem.
This problem will finally tell
us what problems computers can
solve and which ones they can't.
So P is the set of
problems that are
very easy for
computers to solve.
Think about simple math.
5 times 3, 15.
We can do that fast,
so can computers.
But NP is the set
of problems that
are much harder for
computers to solve.
Now, it is generally assumed
that P does not equal NP.
But if P is equal to NP,
and these sets of numbers
are the same, then
the world as we
know it will be very different.
Modern cryptography could
be broken very easily.
And we would have to come up
with a whole body of research
in order to solve this.
Now, this problem made its mass
debut in pop culture in 1995
when it appeared on
a "Simpsons" episode
where Homer was trying to
escape being around his in-laws,
so he went through a door that
went into another dimension.
Now, there's more than
just fame on the line here.
There's $1 million
if you can actually
prove that P is not equal to NP.
Now, it's important to note that
this problem has been around
for a very long time.
This is apparently what people
did on computers in 1971.
And this is when the
problem first came out.
Now, if you're a
computer scientist,
you know that it takes
a long time for people
to solve problems like this.
But this changed
on August 6, 2010.
A researcher from HP Labs
came out with a proof.
He sent it to all the scientists
working on the problem,
including Ron.
But he also posted
it online to script.
Now, a few days
later, aggregators
like Slashdot and Hacker
News picked up on this.
Nerds all over the
world were going crazy.
Somebody had finally proved it.
So I wanted to know,
what did Ron think?
What did all those professional
computer scientists working
on this think?
So I go to Ron's office.
And he's eating a sandwich,
not this sandwich,
but a similar sandwich.
And he says to me, Julia,
things like this take time.
The proof was 100 pages.
And I said, Ron, Twitter
does not have time!
And then he looks at
me perplexed and says,
but how did you know
about this problem?
So by then, something happened
that had never happened before.
TechCrunch published real news.
And suddenly they were talking
about P is equal to NP-- again,
something that had
never occurred.
So did he prove it?
So the answer is maybe,
but probably not.
So like all things
in math and science,
he still believes
the proof holds.
But the general
community believes
the proof does not hold.
But that's not the
point of the story.
The point of the
story is that suddenly
all of these discussions that
used to go on in private email
groups, they're now
happening out in the open.
And then suddenly "The New York
Times" picks up on it as well.
And researchers like Ron and
other people in this community
start issuing public
statements as "The New York
Times" comes knocking
on their door.
And they say things
like, we know
this is a very hard problem
and a very interesting problem.
But we didn't think
anybody really cared.
So the beautiful thing
that happened here
is that suddenly
a community that's
used to talking about
things in private
comes crashing into modern day
Twitter, social media blogs,
and we all can learn
about the awesomeness that
is some of these very hard
computer science problems.
And so maybe the
future millionaire
is in the audience tonight.
Go out and solve P equals NP!
And now Brad is coming on stage.
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD YOUNGGREN: I'm going
to talk a bit about how
medical devices are going to
change the way health care is
delivered in the world
over the next five years.
It's going to allow
people and empower them
to have a more active
role in their health care.
It's kind of like Fitbit
Plus or something like that.
So no longer are
we going to have
to worry about the safety
and efficacy of devices
that we have to interact
with in our lives.
That thing on the left that
you attach to your body,
and it supposedly broke down fat
off your body while you slept.
Or the Fluoroscopy device
on the other image there,
where it was used
for shoe sizing.
Or do-it-yourself kits,
like this gentleman
here in China for 11
years did dialysis at home
because he did not have
access to medical devices.
So he actually figured
out how to do this at 1/10
the cost from his garage,
fascinating story.
But we want to move
beyond that now
and empower people with
real safe and accessible
medical devices.
Patient-centered health
care is where we're moving.
But really, this is
a bidirectional flow
of information between you, as
the patient, and your doctor.
This will be facilitated
by medical devices that
are developed or already on the
market that you could purchase
now or within the next
year to make it better.
Here's an example of
a 14-year-old kid who
developed a stethoscope with a
3D printer earlier last year.
Now, this allows you
to actually digitize
the sounds of your heart.
Why does that matter?
Well, there's usually a lub dub.
But if there's a
lub dub dub, what
we call the S3 in medicine,
that's actually the earliest
predictor of congestive
heart failure you can have.
So no longer do you have to
measure weights and, if you
start gaining weight, call
your provider and say,
I'm gaining weight.
Now you can actually use this
on your own from your house
and communicate that data.
And then your provider can
increase your diuretics
to lower your weight, which will
lower the cost of health care
and keep you out
of the hospital.
So this is a simple device.
But it is very powerful.
CellScope's another
device that came out
in the last year and a half.
This is a device that
allows you to look
at the eardrum of
your child at home.
Fever, ear ache,
where do you go?
You go to the ER, right?
Or the urgent care center.
Now you can look at it at
the comfort of your own home.
It's actually a lot
more powerful now.
Because not only can
you get the information
and interpret it yourself,
you could send that data
to an ENT doctor, who can
look at the data and say,
yes, it's red.
And they can potentially
prescribe medication.
There are 5 million visits in
the US alone for acute otitis
media ear infection, and
10 million prescriptions.
Imagine if those,
the number of visits,
we could decrease by
using telemedicine
for this one simple
problem that we deal with.
So AliveCor gets a lot of press.
You may have heard about this.
It's a single ED
EKG casing that sits
on the back of your smartphone.
It can detect abnormal rhythms,
such as atrial fibrillation--
really important,
because that has
relevance in the
context of stroke.
So this device actually
creates this data
set that could be
sent to the cloud.
And initially they
had a website where
providers can go on
and see the data.
So you could interact
with your physician
remotely about
what's actually going
on with the rhythm
of your heart.
And now those are
being integrated
with electronic medical records.
The cost is already cheaper
than traditional devices
that you would have
to purchase if there's
a question of whether you
had an irregular heartbeat.
It's $225.
You can actually get
that diagnosis made.
And by the way, you own it.
So you can continually use
that device down the road.
Microfluidics-- you're going
to be hearing a lot about this
in the next five years.
It's essentially a
microscope on a chip.
It's got a lot of
plumbing on the chip.
But it allows you to do cheap,
fast point-of-care diagnostics.
Now, that's traditionally
facing towards hospital care.
But you're going
to be able to do it
from the comfort
of your own home.
Cue is coming out
with a device that
will allow you to test
for five different markers
from the comfort
of your own home.
That information
will be Bluetoothed
to your phone, where
you can make changes
on a day to day basis
based on the changes
in that information.
Let's do a quick example here.
It's December.
And you have a fever,
cough, sore throat.
You think you have the flu.
You take the test
with the device.
And that device then
Bluetooths and says,
you have the flu, yes, notifies
your health care provider,
your physician, that in
fact you have the flu.
Then that physician orders
a prescription for you
for that medical problem that
is couriered to you somehow
by Postmates or
something like that.
And then it ends up back at
the comfort of your home.
And you actually
never left your couch.
This is important
for a couple reasons.
One, physicians
really don't want
you to come to the
hospital with influenza.
We don't mind seeing you.
But the problem is
that we don't want
you infecting everyone
else in the room.
And that's the problem
with influenza.
So ultrasound
diagnostics are changing.
In terms of the form factors,
they're becoming much smaller.
And now we're getting a lot
of auto-diagnostic devices
in the market.
So this will allow this
to actually be things
that consumers can
purchase to keep them
from out of the hospital or
going to see their health care
provider and still communicate
the same amount of data.
So at the end of the day,
what we're trying to do here
is create a set
of medical devices
that you, as the
consumer, as the patient,
can be empowered to
increase your communication
with your health care provider
to move it back to a cottage
industry where you actually
have a physical relationship
with your provider.
You can actually talk with them.
So medical devices will help
facilitate that process.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ADRIAN CATALAN: Hey, everyone.
I'm Adrian.
I'm from Guatemala.
I'm the co-founder of a
mobile development studio.
And also, I work at a
university part time.
I'm very curious.
And I believe curiosity,
it's something natural
for human beings.
We are naturally inquisitive.
That's me a few years
ago about to experience
a flow of electrons
passing through my body
for the first time.
As it turns out, you get
a tingling sensation.
Well, I found out, experiment.
Have you ever seen something
and wondered, can I make that?
Or can I make it better?
The world around
us is made by us.
It didn't just exist.
We made it.
It's shaped by us.
I believe making is
natural for every one.
Maybe you have made
some food, some art,
grew a beautiful garden.
In my case, I like
technology very much.
Because I think it's
a huge leverage.
It lets you build a lot
with very little resources.
That's why this is
a tale of making.
I've been teaching
computer science courses
since I was a 20-year-old.
I usually ask my students,
who taught you to ride a bike?
Answers include Mom, Dad.
Then I ask them, do
they use a blackboard?
They didn't.
We learned it by doing.
And there's a sense
of pride in making,
even if it's something as
simple as linking an LED.
That's the [INAUDIBLE]
of the whole world.
The first time you
make this, you're
going to feel like,
I am Prometheus!
I wanted that for as much
people that I can reach.
So in [INAUDIBLE], I started
a lab at Galileo University,
in Guatemala.
I wanted for our engineering
school students to be makers.
We started with warships on
Arduino and Raspberry Pi.
And soon the projects arose.
That's a 3D-printed claw
controlled by the [INAUDIBLE]
motion built using JavaScript.
Yes, you can build robots using
JavaScript thanks to leverage
like Johnny 5.
Robotics is no longer only
four Ph.D. researchers.
Any web developer can be a
robotics maker right away.
That's another project
using the Oculus Rift.
It's telepresence robot.
It uses web cams as its eyes.
You can see the video
remotely using the headset.
When you are making,
you don't need
to know exactly what you're
doing or why you're doing it.
You just need to tinker,
play with the technology,
push it to the edge,
and push yourself
to the edge to see
what you're capable of.
Starting it wasn't easy.
There were like five
Arduinos and 100 students
willing to be makers.
But in time, the warships
proved their worthiness.
And we got some funding.
Also, we got more
goals for reach.
So we started a program called
Engineering Kickstart to get
high school students
interested in technology.
It's a boot camp.
During three weeks,
we show them how
cool it is being an engineer.
Also, we're working
with children.
Sometimes prototyping boards
and soldering irons doesn't fit.
So you can make playdough
right in your kitchen.
A salty recipe conducts
electricity really well.
And a sweet recipe is
resistant to electric currents.
Put that together and
you've got a circuit.
Also, we started
[INAUDIBLE] community
in Guatemala, a community
that's open for everyone.
So we got students
from high school,
from different universities
working side by side.
We'd see some developers.
This is not rocket science.
Well, sometimes it is.
That's a [INAUDIBLE]
rocket built
using plastic bottles
and a Raspberry Pi.
We built it last month
at the conference.
And it flew like an angel.
Surprisingly, it also
landed very well.
This is not a recipe.
We are just learning
how to do this.
This is a work in progress.
We started with warships
then built some crazy ideas
as projects to get
some attention.
And now we're working
on [INAUDIBLE].
The world is inviting us to
play, to roll up our sleeves
and make something.
Being makers is something
that is natural for us.
This is passionate-based
learning.
With making, you can explore
different possibilities
and see what drives you.
What do we really like?
Starting is not easy.
Making needs a lot
of persistence.
But it's for every one.
So go ahead and make something.
If you have a
master's technique,
share it at your local
maker's space or online.
If you're an educator,
these are exciting times.
Because you can be
a maker of makers.
That's my email and my Twitter.
We can use it to follow
the conversation.
I want to finish saying, let's
go and make something together.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DEAN PUTNEY: So a
couple years ago my mom
dropped this photo album,
a family photo album,
into my lap, basically.
And it was a
collection of photos
that my great
grandfather, Walter,
took when he was in World
War I in the German army.
And I fell in love
with it immediately.
It's an incredible collection.
It's got hundreds
of photos in it.
I think that this
is just fantastic.
It's got these great
photos of people sledding.
And he's basically brought his
camera all around with him.
And I wanted to preserve it.
My family basically
put me in charge
of preserving it and
keeping it in good stead
and sharing it with the world.
So I started to think
about some of my experience
with photography.
I'd been very interested in
photography for many years.
I took a lot of courses in
college about photography.
And I had a real favorite
which was a two-part course
on the history of photography,
taught by Linda Benedict-Jones.
And Linda, she's a real expert
in fine art photography.
She basically started
the Polaroid collection
and curated it for many years.
And now she's the curator of
the photography department
at the Carnegie Museum
of Art in Pittsburgh.
So I was reminded of
a lot of the things
that we talked about in Linda's
class, a lot of the photos
that we looked at.
And I decided I should
call Linda up and see
what she had to say
about how to preserve it
and how best to get it,
the artistic community,
interested in it.
Unfortunately, that was a
little bit of a dead end.
Linda said that the museum is
mostly interested in preserving
the works of fine artists,
well-known artists.
And nobody had ever
heard of Walter before.
But I still felt
that it really needed
to belong in a
museum at some point.
But at the same
time I thought, I'll
take a different direction.
I'm an internet guy.
What can I do with
these photos now?
So I started digitizing them
and sharing them online.
I took photos of all
the pages and made
sure that they made
sense in a Flickr album.
And then I looked for
a new target audience.
And I decided if I can't get
in touch with the artists yet,
let's get in touch
with the history people
who are going to be very
much interested in this.
And I put it on Reddit.
And they loved it.
They tore the whole album apart.
They made extensive
detailed notes
on almost every photo in the
whole album, like 700 photos.
They found all these
locations and places
that Walter had been.
And I actually went to this
cathedral in northern France
and re-took his photo.
And Walter had a really
interesting approach
to how he took photos.
And how you could see in
that last photo there,
he was taking images
inside these cathedrals
where the roof was
blown out, basically.
And I decided that
the thing to do
was to make a reproduction
of Walter's albums
so that you could see
the context of the war
and the context of all
the photos together.
And what I did was I
went to Kickstarter.
And I kept Linda's
artistic community in mind
and kept the idea of making
a really high-quality album
in mind.
I set the goal pretty high.
Because I wanted to do
justice for Walter's photos,
make a really
excellent reproduction.
And it turns out that
Kickstarter isn't just
a crowdfunding platform.
It's a reputation platform, too.
And that's where I built
Walter's reputation
as an artist as well as an
historical value, basically.
And I wound up getting in
touch with a lot of people
through the Kickstarter
who reached out to me.
I did an interview with the
"Daily Mail" at like 4 o'clock
in the morning on, like, the
second day of this Kickstarter.
Because people are
watching Kickstarter
trying to find out what
these new things are
and trying to find out
about the next big thing
that's coming out.
So the project doubled its goal.
It raised $113,000.
And I drove directly
into making the album
as an art object
in itself, making
it as beautiful as possible.
I used really thick
paper, nice printing.
And in January every one
received their books.
And they were just
totally surprised.
They were not expecting this
history book to be so nice.
And I took a page out of "How
to Win Friends & Influence
People," one of my favorite
books, where I basically kept
Linda in touch about
and up to date on what
the project was doing.
And I asked her
for a small favor
to write the forward
for the book.
And when I finished,
when it was printed,
I sent her a copy
as a thank you.
And all that hard work paid off.
Because Linda called me up a
couple days later and said,
can we put Walter's
photos in the museum?
So here they are,
beginning of this month.
Here they are in the
Carnegie Museum of Art.
And they did a beautiful
job setting it up.
And now Walter's photos
are put in a context
of a real artist, where
he is recognized now.
And right down that
hallway on the left
is one of Monet's
paintings of water lilies.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRADY FORREST: Our next
speaker was here-- actually,
our next speaker spoke
at the very first Ignite.
And he was at last
year's Ignite I/O,
where he talked about better
living through Bluetooth.
I think this talk would
be called "Better living
through Kickstarter,"
or this segment.
Please welcome up
Seattle's Dan Shapiro.
DAN SHAPIRO: Thank you, Brady.
So when I graduated college,
I told my friend, Kevin,
I have an engineering degree.
If I go to work for
a software company,
put a bullet in my head,
put me out of my misery.
I want to make things.
Fortunately, he didn't listen.
And after 15 and 1/2
years building software,
I decided last year
to take a breather,
take a leave of absence
over the summer,
and spend some time
with the family.
Well, I don't write code.
I'm a product guy.
I do a little bit.
But it's always amazed me that
the most modern programming
languages are still
backwards-compatible
with the VT100 terminal.
Where else is ASCII
the state of the art?
I always thought,
shouldn't there
be a way that programming
could be more expressive?
I had this idea running
around in my head.
At the same time,
my four-year-olds
were getting into games.
And I was faced with
the unpleasant decision
between the Candy Land school
of completely random luck
and the Tic Tac Toe school
of trying to throw the game
and hope your kids don't notice.
And I wanted something better.
So I thought, OK, what is going
to entertain four-year-olds?
Computer science.
I had this notion,
kind of half-baked,
they were going to play code
cards and write a program.
I was going to be the computer.
I was going to run the program.
And thus was born Robot
Turtles out of a PowerPoint
deck and art supplies.
My kids loved it.
The first time we
played, my daughter
said, Daddy, I don't
like the walls.
I said, what should
we do about it?
She said, lasers!
So it went like this
with my collaborators,
developing the game.
At the same time, I was talking
with a crazy friend of mine
who wanted to put his
family album on Kickstarter.
We would chat every
night via Skype.
Of course, his project was
completely doomed to fail.
But I learned a lot
from our conversations.
We talked about what I call
"the Curly rule," for those
of you who've seen
"City Slickers."
It's that Kickstarters,
great Kickstarters,
are about one thing, one thing
you want to exist in the world.
And when people want that
thing to exist with you,
they succeed.
We talked about what I think
of as the platonic ideal
of Kickstarters and how to
find it, which is you back
a whole bunch of stuff.
And then you look for the common
threads, the platonic ideal,
of those successful campaigns.
Platonic ideal,
Vitruvian Kickstarter--
So for example,
great communications,
regular updates, having a
story around what you do--
and we were talking
about all this.
And I got jealous.
I decided that I wanted to
do a Kickstarter, myself.
So I decided to get
a designer first.
I found this guy in Indonesia.
He was amazing.
I was up till 3:00
AM every morning
polishing the art
for Robot Turtles.
Then I had to figure
out manufacturing,
which is an exhausting process.
I Googled "board
game manufacturers"
and called everybody
who came up.
Wound up with a
century-old company
called DeLano Services, who
did an amazing job printing it.
Had to figure out shipping.
Amazon's cheapest for domestic.
Did you know that
it costs $72 to send
three pounds of cardboard
to Tauranga, New
Zealand. [MOUTH POPPING] So
having got all that sorted out,
I had to set a goal.
The key for me was
figuring out, what
was the number I
would be happy with?
I set it at $25,000, which I
thought I could probably hit.
And I'd lose money.
And I'd have some leftovers.
But at least I'd have
something to give away
at school auctions for
the rest of my life.
So I put it up for $25,000.
Ah, but how to let
people find out?
I'm not proud of this.
I've emailed 3,003
people in my life.
And I emailed every
single one of them
to tell them about the
Kickstarter campaign.
Three told me never
to email them again.
And then something
crazy happened.
The project fully funded
in the first five hours.
A day later, it hit $100,000.
It went on to be the
most-backed board
game in Kickstarter history.
People asked me
how this happened.
The best thing I can
explain is that this
was something people
wanted to exist.
This was something, a board
game that teaches programming
to preschoolers, that
wasn't out there.
I talked to a friend in
the board game industry.
She said, computer
programming is too esoteric.
People don't want games
that require grownups.
They want games where the
kids can go and entertain
themselves in the
corners by themselves.
Well, my Kickstarter
backers did want this.
And they brought
it into existence.
So I listened to them.
I resigned my
awesome job at Google
and spent the next
few months delivering
to 65 countries, three semi
truck loads of cardboard,
36 tons shipped
around the world.
I got outreach from
amazing board game
manufactures and
partnered with a company
called ThinkFun, one of the
best in educational board games,
whose CEO actually was the
brother of Dennis Ritchie,
the guy who wrote
the programming
book I learned from.
And you can now
find it on Amazon.
Next week it'll be in
Target stores nationwide.
And would you believe
it, a board game
about computer programming
was on the front page
of "The New York Times."
This thing needed to exist.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And it was only by
putting it out there
that I found that out.
So I think I was on to something
back when I was in college.
It's really cool to
build things in software.
But making something you
can hold in your hands
that the world wants, that
you can share with them,
there's some real magic there.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
ARTURO JAMAICA: Right.
Hi.
My name is Arturo Jamaica.
I'm from Mexico.
And I'm going to talk to you
about how I hacked and stopped
a $9.3 million fraud in Mexico.
So I live in a city
named Queretaro.
That is two hours Mexico City.
Myself, I have been doing
software development
since the last 10 years.
I am 24 years old.
I do a lot of stuff--
mobile, back-end
integrated with a lot of stuff.
And I started a company in
Mexico named Brounie, which
the logo's a cupcake-- but
never mind-- where we usually
do apps for clients
for a lot of people.
We work, 12 people.
I am the biggest
guy in the company.
We all are college students.
We don't have any funding.
And we're working.
One day I get to the newspaper,
the most important newspaper
in my country, and I read this--
"congressman pay $9.3 million
in order to get an app."
For me it was crazy.
Because I manage every month
to work with my students
and pay the bills that I
have to do to run my company.
This was compared
821 Angry Birds
if you want to make the game
with the same amount of money.
So I was really angered.
I was really thinking
about-- I was
losing a big deal that
we can make cheaper.
So it was like someone
putting a knife in my back
and telling me,
your country doesn't
want you to do
software for them.
Because they wanted to
pass it to another people.
Because all of our
business in Mexico
is passing on corruption.
So there was this idea of
one guy to turn it down.
So we decided to make the app
totally free using a contest.
So what I did first, I basically
hacked the congress website
in order to scrap it and get out
all the information that they
need and tell everyone
to use it freely
so we can offer information.
This was done in March of 2010.
Then I released on the
day of my birthday, which,
instead of celebrating, I
coded the app in three days,
in order to give it away and
give it open-source to everyone
that can handle it.
So you can use this app for
learning or for [INAUDIBLE].
They made a contest in
order to clean their hands
and don't seem very
bad about the press.
And I got an iPad and $1,000.
But for me, it was
very significant
because I got attention
from a lot of people.
Because it was bigger news
that some guys in college-- I
was 23 years old
then-- had the idea.
We also got in TechCrunch all of
the fancy sites, all the news.
So that came along for
us, a very good first time
in order to find
a lot of people.
This wasn't done just by me.
Also, it was done by a
lot of people in Mexico,
and also a lot of my team
that put work on this.
We don't charge a thing.
We also make on the
top applications
on the Android and iOS devices.
And it's all wielding
Google technology.
So that was how I
hacked the congress
and saved a lot of
money to my country.
And this is my contact stuff.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN USSERY: Hello.
My name's Brian Ussery.
And I'm a Top Contributor in
the Google Webmaster Help forum.
This is my sixth Google
I/O. And I'm always
amazed by the number of
developers who aren't familiar
with the Google product forums
or with the Top Contributor
program.
So that's what I'm going
to be talking about today.
When I say Google
product forums,
I'm actually just talking
about the groups that
provide technical support
for all of Google's products.
And they're available any
time you have problems.
That should be one of
the absolute first places
that you go to get help.
So whenever you actually
go in the forums itself,
you will find different badges.
And the blue badges means
that the individual who
posts, that they're
a Google employee.
The yellow badge indicates that
it's a Rising Star, somebody
who's a rising star in the
Top Contributor program.
And then there's the
Top Contributors.
This is actually
an elite program.
It provides all types of
testing opportunities,
Trusted Tester,
product knowledge,
a number of insights.
This is actually a question
that a first-time developer
posted in the Chrome Help forum.
And it was able
to actually cause
Google to change the Fact
page in the Chrome Help forum.
So personally, I enjoy
helping other people.
I enjoy meeting with
other Top Contributors,
coming out to California to go
to Google, going to the 'plex,
testing out new
products, great swag.
There are a number of
different benefits.
This is kind of the
road to becoming a TC.
First of all, you find
a forum that you're
interested in that you have some
knowledge about, participate.
Normally you're
contacted by Google.
And you'll become a Rising Star.
And then eventually you
become a Top Contributor.
And these are some of
the Top Contributors.
Believe it or not,
Google actually
has 250 Help forums
for 25 products
in 30 different languages.
And the Top Contributors
are actually
the most helpful and
best people in the forums
in terms of answering
questions according to Google.
There are actually a
number of Top Contributors
who are developers.
So I'm not the only one.
If you need help with
Chrome, Gmail, what have you,
there's a number of different
people who can help.
Top Contributors are some of the
most helpful and active people
in the Help forums.
They are always
providing support
and helping to educate
and help other users
to be the best that they
can with whatever product.
They're very visible,
in this case,
"in their pajamas" visible.
Whenever they're not
helping other people,
you can find Top
Contributors hosting things
like Webmaster
Help Desk Hangouts.
That is a live Hangout
that's every week.
Top Contributors are technical.
They know the ins and
outs of Google products
from a technical standpoint.
And they're always
willing to help.
A lot of times they're
actually working
on creating additional
technical content
to help other users
with the products.
They're knowledgeable.
Top Contributors are actually
trusted Google partners
who connect
regularly with Google
to stay in the know about the
latest products and updates.
So why should you join?
Being a Top Contributor
actually provides you
with a number of opportunities
to increase your own product
technical knowledge.
And that's one of the most
beneficial things for me,
is knowing about what's going
to happen before it comes out.
You also get to give
feedback on Google products,
Trusted Tester opportunities.
And that's something
that's also really unique.
Whenever you're a
Top Contributor,
you actually team up with
a Google community manager.
So you're constantly in
connection with them,
talking with them.
And that's a very
unique experience, too.
Because there were years when
people would be like, well,
how do I call Google?
And I didn't have any idea.
So one of the coolest
things about it,
honestly, too, is you get
to help and inspire others.
You get to help change
the world and make it
a better place, if you will.
You're actually answering
thousands of questions.
And people constantly are
referring back to these.
But honestly, it's
also a lot of fun.
This is actually a
picture from our TC Summit
that was in Mountain
View last October.
And Google flies everybody out
there from around the world.
And it's just a lot of fun.
So if you're interested in
becoming a Top Contributor
or learning more about
the program, contact me.
There are a number of Top
Contributors out here.
And there are also a
number of Googlers.
Feel free to ask any of us.
Thank you and have a good day.
[APPLAUSE]
BRADY FORREST: I would like
to apologize in advance
for just how morbid
this next talk is
and for the amount
of glee that you
will see from this adult
version of Wednesday.
Please welcome up
Danielle Leong.
DANIELLE LEONG: Hi.
My name is Danielle.
And today I'm going to talk to
you about forensic entomology,
which is the study
of the insects that
eat you when you die.
I hope none of you are hungry.
Because it's going
to be disgusting.
So a quick confession-- I
have photographic evidence
that I have always been a nerd.
So here I am.
I actually interned at the San
Mateo County Mosquito Abatement
lab.
And I also went to CSI camp.
It was totally a thing.
It was fantastic.
You all missed out, because
you're no longer 17.
So there was this is
one time at CSI camp
where I was sitting
in a lecture.
And all of a sudden this man
comes out of the back room
and shoots our
professor in the head.
We're like, oh my god!
Do we still have to
take the mid-term?
The answer is yes, we did.
But our professor gets up
off the ground and says,
each one of you has been
a witness to a crime.
How many shots were fired?
What did the
assailant look like?
What race was he?
How heavy was he?
And out of 200 students,
not a single one of us
had the same answer as
the person next to us.
So the moral of the story
is that eyewitnesses
are incredibly unreliable,
unless you have Neil deGrasse
Tyson as your witness.
That man's word is God.
You should never,
ever rely on witnesses
if you want to win your case.
So forensic entomology
is incredibly important
to police work.
Because insects provide physical
evidence of time of death.
It takes a specific amount
of time for an insect
to get from egg, to larva,
to pupa, to an adult.
And so since insects don't have
stretchy skin, as they grow,
they molt.
Each one of these molts
is called an instar.
Blow flies, for example,
have three instars
that they go through.
And so if you can count how many
of each specific type of insect
and each specific
instar are on a body,
you can actually get a pretty
accurate time of death.
So there are certain things
that can affect an insect's life
cycle.
For example, if the body's
in a barrel, if it's wet,
if it's hot, if it's cold.
All of these things can
either slow down or speed up
the growth cycle of an insect.
Now, there are ways that
you can measure this.
There are things called
body farms, which
are super creepy
laboratories where scientists
can go and measure the effects
of these different types
of variables.
So there are just
bodies in car trunks
just hanging out in the field.
So the first one was actually
in the University of Tennessee.
Now, there are five
stages of decomposition.
And each one of them comes
with their own insect.
The first one is initial decay.
This happens immediately
when you die.
Flies just come out of nowhere.
I don't know how they find you.
But they find you.
They will find you.
And they will just start
laying eggs in your eyes
and in your mouth and any other
kind of orifice they can find.
And so when those
eggs hatch-- we're
very familiar with maggots.
Those are blow fly larvas.
And this is also
how we get ants.
So this is about three--
immediately after death,
and till three days after.
Next up we have putrefaction.
And this is when the
naturally-occurring bacteria
and digestive
enzymes in your gut
start to eat away
at your organs.
And they release carbon dioxide.
And they make you
start to bloat.
This actually happens
at initial decay.
But this is when you
get exceptionally puffy.
So we have our maggots.
They have gone through several
stages of their instars.
We also have the appearance
of the carrion beetle
as well as the rove beetle.
And we also still have ants.
Because your body's
still very soft.
So they can chew away at
you and take you away.
Next up is my
favorite stage of all,
which is black putrefaction.
And this is when
your body explodes.
And it's black.
And it's disgusting.
And it smells.
And this is when your neighbors
find out that you're dead.
It's fantastic!
It's the best one out there.
So remember our blow flies, it
takes a specific amount of time
from egg to larva.
Now we have reached
the pupa stage.
They're burrowing through the
carpet underneath your body.
We also have the appearance
of the black scavenger fly
as well as our carrion
and our rove beetles.
Next up we have
butyric fermentation.
And this is when your
body starts to dry out.
And it smells like cheese.
I hope you're still hungry.
And this is because
of the butyric acid
that your body is producing.
So this is about 20 to
50 days after death.
And with butyric
fermentation, you
get the appearance
of the cheese fly.
And the cheese fly
is my favorite fly.
Because if I was a fly,
I would be a cheese fly.
Because then you
could live in cheese.
And honestly, who
doesn't want to do that?
And we also have the
appearance of our skin beetle
as well as our black
scavenger fly, as well,
and our carrion beetles.
Our last stage of
decomposition is dry decay.
And it's pretty
self explanatory.
Your body has exploded.
There's not a whole
lot of fluids.
It's dry.
It does happen in humid weather.
But it's not really
that interesting.
It's mites and moths and
boring stuff like that.
So a quick recap--
eyewitnesses are terrible.
If you want to
win your case, you
want to have as much physical
evidence as possible.
Insects help provide physical
evidence of time of death.
There are five stages
of decomposition.
And each one of them comes
with their own insects,
like the cheese fly.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY SALO: My goodness, how
do you follow a talk like that?
Two weeks ago I
submitted an essay
that explained why I wanted
to come to Google I/O.
Because I didn't have
a registration code.
I explained how I wanted
to come and understand
how Google products and services
would help create what I'm
calling "the internet
of natural things."
Next thing I knew, ReadWrite
gave me a registration code.
So I engaged in a little
bit of essay reuse
and submitted that
essay and said
I wanted to explain how
Google ought to participate
in creating this
large scale, wide area
collection of wireless
sensor networks.
OK, it was a little
bit presumptuous.
But it got me an
Ignite presentation.
So why are these
things interesting?
They're interesting
because I want
to collect sensor data
from large, remote areas,
like watershed-sized areas--
maybe hundreds or thousands
of square miles.
Why do I want that data?
Hydrologists use that
data to, for example,
create flood warnings
and flood forecasts.
Floods are the most
deadly natural disaster
in this country after heat.
And of course, you need
that data in a big hurry.
Better data, quicker data
means better forecasts,
more lives saved, and
more property preserved.
Also, 80% of our
fresh water resources
originate in forested areas.
In order to protect our
fresh water resources,
we need to understand what's
happening in those areas.
And of course, climate
change compels us.
Climate change really drives
us to want to better understand
these remote areas
so that we can better
adapt to a changing environment.
There is the problem,
small problem,
of getting the data
out of these areas.
It's the last
tens-of-miles problem.
These areas are areas that don't
have common infrastructure,
such as cellular service,
internet service.
They don't even have
commercial electrical power.
So one solution is use
radios to get these data out,
such as the radios that are
used on police cars, taxicabs,
and amateur radio operators.
These radios, you do
have to deploy them.
And they're really slow, at
least by today's standards.
You can get data out.
It may be 9.6
kilobits per second.
But amateur radio
operators are experimenting
with other technologies.
Throughout the world, hundreds
of amateur radio operators
have attached a radio and a
camera to weather balloons
and released them.
They rise to 100,000 feet
and take beautiful pictures.
At 100,000 feet, when
these balloons burst,
the sky is black.
And you can even see the
curvature of the Earth.
And of course, since
these have radios
that are broadcasting
their location,
the amateurs can
chase after them
and recover them and
get neat pictures.
Since the 1960s
other radio amateurs
have been creating
communication satellites that
allow amateurs to
communicate with each other
through low earth
orbit satellites.
And this has created a worldwide
network of amateur radio
operators who can
provide ground stations,
ground support, and
manage these satellites.
In fact, there's a small
satellite from NASA--
which isn't an
amateur satellite,
but it's similar-- that is
using these same amateur radio
operators to collect
telemetry for NASA,
a low-cost, free ground station.
Oh, and by the way, that
was a picture of PhoneSat.
And you guessed it.
It's driven-- its main
computer is an Android phone.
There's the proof-of-concept
project by NASA.
So in order to create
these things, in order
to create this internet
of natural things,
we need some collaborations.
And Google has just
the projects that I
think ought to participate.
You've all heard of Project
Loon, the balloon internet
project by Google that will
provide internet service
to remote areas with
high-altitude balloons are
circulating the Earth.
I'd like for those balloons
also to provide internet service
to remote sensors, to
this remote internet
of natural things.
And if you've read
the newspaper,
Google has promised, apparently,
according to news reports,
to invest billions of
dollars in a constellation
of low earth-orbit
satellites that
will also provide
internet service.
I think that Google ought to
use these satellites to connect
my networks in remote areas to
provide internet service so we
can get those hydrologic data
quicker from more remote areas.
And it's not just hydrologists
that want these data.
Meteorologists want it.
Researchers want it.
And I think Google wants it.
After all, Google,
according to press reports,
has recently entered
into an agreement where
they will make climate change
available over the web.
What better place to
deliver this sensor data?
And collaborations are required
to create this project,
to wire the internet,
and to wire the planet.
And I think the particularly
interesting collaborations
are, I think, that Google-- if
I might say presumptuously--
I would like to see Google
Project Loon and the LEO
satellites collaborate with
amateur radio operators.
Amateur radio operators
get new toys to play with.
And Google gets free
ground station services
throughout the globe
that will provide them
telemetry and
management services.
And of course, not only will
this project wire the planet
and save the Earth,
it's also part
of my dissertation research.
And so maybe it'll
help me graduate, too.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRADY FORREST: We're down
to our last two speakers.
And this next speaker is what
I would call a web theorist.
Please welcome up Kevin Marks.
KEVIN MARKS: So
in ancient Greece
there was a road called
the Way of Miracles
that went from
Athens to Eleusis.
People would go there to get
to the holy places in Greece.
And on that road was a
man called Procrustes,
who would get people
to stay in his bed
at night, except that
if they didn't fit,
he'd cut off their feet
or stretch them out
on the rack to make them fit.
And my point is that we
tend to do this in computing
quite a lot, too.
If you're younger than
me, you may not remember.
But we used to have to
use file names like this
and compress every thought
we had into 8.3 characters.
And the three were
predefined by the apps.
So we really had eight.
But things get better over time.
Now in Runescape
you can have things
that are worth up to
2.147 billion gold coins.
Because they used a java.lang to
store the amount of gold coins
something could be worth.
If you have a
database of customers
that has zip codes
in it, you may
wonder why you have so
many users in Beverly Hills
and Schenectady.
Because you ask every customer
to fill in a zip code.
But there seem to be more than
the population would predict.
Because these are
the zip codes people
use when they're lying to you.
Or they don't have a
zip code because they
come from another country.
And so by forcing them to put
something in the database,
you're forcing them
to make something
up and destroy your data.
Another example here--
this is a database
that's asking you
for your gender.
And the programmer clearly
wanted you to use one bit
and then said, oh, OK.
You can be other or decline
to state if you really insist.
And this is a problem.
Because gender isn't one bit.
It's more of an essay
question for a lot of people.
There's a site called
Genderfork, which is explicitly
about people discussing gender
and how they feel about it
and how it makes them
interact with others.
It's very hard to fit
that into one bit.
So databases are
part of the problem.
I don't need to
recite this cartoon.
You've all seen it.
But databases by
their very nature
force us to think of
the world as data,
not as the world itself.
But we put the databases first.
Object orientation
can be bad, too.
If you [INAUDIBLE]
inherits, you end up
having volcanoes that
have fax numbers.
Because it seemed logical
that places had fax numbers.
So it's very hard to
get this modeling right.
XML was an attempt to do better,
to let you construct arbitrary
documents that
contained other things.
But they kept the Procrustean
thing by making it draconian.
So if you made a
mistake, that was it.
The processing would stop.
And you had to throw it out.
Whereas HTML was very
accepting of areas and let
you produce large
documents with it.
Anything in it took
off, took over the web.
And XML is sort of petering
out on the sidelines.
But what this meant
was you then had
to try and make sense
for these HTML, which
is where we got the
idea of big data.
But it's not really
about big data.
It's about messy data.
It's about data that is
produced by people as text
as representations of
things that don't actually
fit into the databases.
So what do we do?
We come up with
techniques like MapReduce,
where you take all this
messy data on the left
and squeeze it through
the Procrustean map
and then shuffle it and end up
with the database on the right,
which looks nice and orderly.
But in fact, you've applied that
Procrustean process on the way
in.
This is a well-known
list of things
that people get
wrong about names.
It really won't
fit into an Ignite.
But there are many
of them there.
And then what you do is you
write a MapReduce to try
and find what real names
are across the web,
which is how we end up
with Google+ nymwars,
where the rule is not,
this has to be your name,
this has to be a name that
fits the algorithm that thinks
it's a name.
And that's another example
of this Procrustean squeezing
of the world into space.
The biggest problem, though,
is plausibility of stories.
We tend to construct stories
and prefer the stories
and then retell them
over time, which
is another Procrustean
try for ourselves.
Because Procrustes
never existed.
But yet this 3,000-year-old
story about a guy who cuts
people's feet off on the road
between Athens and Eleusis is
so compelling that I'm still
using it as a metaphor 3,000
years later.
And people have been doing
this for all that time.
So the real
challenge is if we're
going to build
standards and databases,
remember that they're
documentation, not legislation.
Make sure that you can
actually reproducibly prove
and s your working while
you're doing what you're doing,
document an empirical process.
And these were a
couple of the standards
that I've worked
on that try really
hard to document every piece
of the process along the way
and have an empirical way
of deciding what to use.
Thank you.
BRADY FORREST: Well, thank
you very much for coming out.
I hope to see you
again next year,
doing Ignite in your hometown.
Thank you.
I'm Brady.
[APPLAUSE]